it was with a gamara boss said come to
speak to Manana the guy who had done
something to them had lived in our area
he was well known towards he'd done work
with my family
and he'd he disrespected them somehow to
do with the job with something they'd
done and he came to ask permission to
kill him I knew someone was going to get
killed and
stop it
[Music]
in Calabria there's the andrankato mafia
which andrina means like family united
family my actual family is from Southern
Italy which is the Tower of Italy
Calabria
uh like you've got the COS on Austrian
Sicily gamara in in Naples the andrina
is the calabrian so as I said we're from
generations of that when my father is
and my grandma my Nonna they decided to
my man I decided to leave calabri and go
up north to Milan in the early 60s and
still affiliated with the family down
south but it was an element aside to
them but always had the backup of them
there were
um uh smuggling cigarettes from
Switzerland
um
that's the beginning of it and then uh
they eventually got to hard drugs and
all the rest my mother was English and
my father is Italian
uh she was an au pair she went over to
Italy in the early 70s sorry late 60s
and
she met my father there within a couple
of months she got pregnant with me
couldn't speak any English
till I came over here when I was nine
I had to go straight to school and and
learn and within a couple of years I was
just like another English child of my
age of 11 going to high school and then
as I VA my mother took me back to Italy
so I lived in the UK from the edge of
nine but I yearned to go back to my
family there over here my family they
weren't very you know there wasn't many
of them the Italian family and much
warmer in the way of this sort of very
family orientated where I'm not saying
that here that in the UK but not as but
it was a totally different way of life
over there uh in Italy so I yearn for
that I earned to see my cousins my
aunties my uncles and you know to Philly
belonging the closeness the love the
Loyalty The everything that comes with
it how much did you know about who your
dad was what was he doing whilst you
were growing up my father by them was on
the Run
for murder he ran off to he was a
fugitive in America
so I didn't see him from the age of nine
till I was 13. so of course
he then got arrested in America
extradited to Italy
uh convicted of manslaughter people
asked me you know what age did I realize
there's something going on and that was
the age 13. did I sort of put into
obviously everyone to see my father in
prison but to be fair was in and out
when I was younger so but that happens
elsewhere with other families but
they're not the mafia if you will so
with with our family it was
the element of the organized crime that
I didn't quite know until I was that age
at 13 and then
um
and even then it's like this you do
still don't realize the seriousness of
it
and I suppose when you the the
importance in a way of
I was my Daddy's Little Princess I was
his you know the apple of his eye
as soon as I was 17 I met the father of
my child Lara he was actually
um from a bakery there were Bakers his
family very normal
I remember I didn't like him at first
but all the girls were after him and I
didn't like the way that he was because
of that but then he made me laugh so
much that I fell for him the family
weren't happy about that my dad wasn't
he was still in prison so then my nun
intervened and said no they're in love
leave him alone you've got to accept it
from my my dad accepted that
so I had big daddy issues as well back
then because my father never had time
for me
um he'd get like five kilos of gold from
a payment
and or to pay something with and he'd
take a bracelet out and come on
and I'd like yeah nice but it wasn't
that that I wanted
it was the time with him and my father
always wanted a boy
and he always made sure that
I sort of knew about it indirectly
so there's an occasion when I was eight
years old and he took me to a restaurant
with some of his friends and he sat
there and he said oh I want this boy I
want this boy I want this boy
and I must start crying apparently I
think a lot of my getting involved in it
wasn't about the power or the about the
money or about the it was a love the
Loyalty The the need of him
so by the time of 18 I have moved back
to Milan
um
sort of on the sidelines of the
organization then slowly I become
involved and more involved more involved
with things mainly the money side of it
the laundering so taking money to pay
for shipments of cannabis
and by this time the class A drugs such
as
cocaine mostly and heroin they were into
it was supplying a lot of Europe with it
as well of course ecstasy tablets have
just come out then so they were swapping
in deals and I was the one that I didn't
ever go and get the drugs or see them or
I was the one that went to pay for them
or put the money in the bank
now I know that I mean it's a big
responsibility and I mean I was
19 you know 19 20 21 it was all them
years of I look at my children now and I
think oh my God
I wouldn't ever put that that
responsibility in that onto them
especially with crime but
I had all that and I never had an adult
take me to one side and say this is
wrong this is the seriousness of what
you're doing it becomes a life you
become so
so into that that it becomes that it's
normal whatever normal is
it becomes like and just you know people
say well how can I knew right from wrong
and I know I'm not a bad person I like
to think I'm not a bad person but
it just I can't even explain but it
becomes a normal way of life and when
everybody's in it and everybody's doing
it
that's how it was
so how did it progress from money
laundering up
from that my dad got arrested
over small things
and this was back in 92 so he managed
them to escape he was then a fugitive he
went on the Run he went across to Spain
and Portugal that's where he was
arrested the next year
so as soon he was arrested in 93 of
course as a fugitive he could still run
his and you know role is his his
organization but then he got arrested in
Portugal in 93.
so I had to step in I had by then pulled
myself out massively from the
organization because I just had my
daughter in 91. I become I became a mum
a reality slapped me in the face and I
really put my I actually wanted to get
out because I realized more and more the
seriousness of everything that was going
to happen
so and of course him being arrested had
to pull me back in because
you know when there's ships down
everybody comes to eat you know they all
want a piece of everything to the point
where my uncle even threatened me to
take over my dad's operations
I stepped in I went to see him in prison
every week I used to travel from Milan
they'd arrested my then husband the
father of my daughter
so I used to travel to from Milan to
Madrid on a Saturday see my ex-husband
and travel that same evening to Lisbon
and then go to I think it was all Porto
prison there to see my father on the
Sunday and a Sunday night get the plane
back to Milan so that was for a year
that was my life what kind of decisions
you had to make though I was uh things
like with shipment of something didn't
go right there was tons like five tons
at a time coming across of cannabis and
it was being distributed distributed all
over it I think there's nine countries
involved
in Holland Germany just across Europe it
was going I mean I used to wear Bridget
Jones knickers and go and take hundreds
of thousands just tucked in my knickers
on airplanes you know abroad
what would you say was kind of the most
serious thing you were involved in when
you look back at her
being the most serious is I knew someone
was going to get killed and I couldn't
stop it
and that's the most thing that Carrie
that had the heaviest weight on my
shoulders because of that because it's
somebody that I knew and I knew his wife
and his children
and it was with a gamara boss said come
to speak to Manana my dad they actually
got life for this
and
um
the guy who had done something to them
had lived in our area he was well known
towards he'd done work with my family
and he'd he disrespected them somehow to
do with the job with something he'd done
and he came to ask permission to kill
him
on our grounds if you will
so I overheard all this is talked about
in the kitchen and I overheard it I was
probably about 19.
and um so I think that well what was I
supposed supposed to go to the police
was I supposed to tell well no you can't
do this or because they the gamara would
have turned on us
they would have started a war so we
can't you can't just it's not that
simple to stop something
and I always say that you know I can't
uh and I think that's probably the the
most the worst thing ever is knowing
someone was going to die
and the pain and the that family will
have had and and I knew when it happened
as well
you know and I knew
and not stopping that at that age I let
it go over my head
but he was always there in my
subconscious because as I got older you
know I'm talking about all this now the
way that I am but there's been buckets
of Tears in between all this
whilst your dad isn't is in this prison
in Portugal and you're running the
organization I want to ask you about
your grand and what was her role was she
still actively part of organization what
was she running things well yeah
choose the logistics
so without Manama my dad couldn't run
his organization and without my dad she
couldn't run it so he was the one that
was out there getting all the business
and
becoming because the mentality was quite
restricted to be in Italy
my dad was the one that took it outside
of Italy that it went big and Global you
know and and into so
was still there at that time when I had
to take over she wasn't very happy about
taking over but it was mainly because
mother trusted Manan manana
but he didn't trust her with the money
because she was very weak with the other
with my dad's siblings
they were very you know a lot were
takers and uh didn't didn't pull away in
the organization but expected nice
things and so it was there the the
weakness that she had of giving to
others
it wasn't because he didn't trust her I
mean I've read that her nickname was
Nano Heron yeah
well that's like newspapers I've got a
name to that and
that again you know she was she was that
and this is a woman that couldn't read
or write
she couldn't she had no education she'd
come from Southern Italy with no
having the first child she had at 16 she
was you know so but she was so clever in
other ways she was so mind I mean she
died she was she was still in house
arrest at 86.
and she couldn't even move physically
but the police would be like no she her
mind is too
she's too dangerous her mind is damn
laughing at it but but my none
it was all about feeding a family it was
all about a way of
earning money
to the point where
because my I mean probably about four of
my siblings have died of heroin
and she was so scared of them going out
there and getting it from someone then
it wasn't any God that would they would
overdose that she would give it to them
herself
and as a mother you know that is Harsh
that is you know everybody you can stand
back and be judgmental about that
but actually
when you live in that world and you know
what's out there and what you do you
protect you took them to reamp she paid
thousands to get them right it bribed
them with new cars and gold and
everything it didn't work
so you know I'm not I'm not saying that
it's that it's right
but what I'm saying is it was it wrong
as a mother for you know it's like each
to them each you just don't know until
you're in a situation like that you do
not know how you would act
how long did your crime career last for
till you got into prison well um there
was a few arrests in 93
in Italy it was because people started
talking they got arrested and
and started talking which one of them
was my dad's sister
so she basically took the whole
organization down
especially a mother my father her own
son
and I had them weekends where I used to
go to Portugal to Madrid and
I just before I got on because I used to
have to leave my daughter with my
in-laws at the time she was only about
two
so I used to check in and ring and say
right and I'm going to get the flight
I'm coming home
and they said don't come back there's
been loads of arrests of your family
uh don't come back so I had to just get
my my back off the planes and an
emergency got off the plane got the next
flight to London
then up north to my mother
and I was absolutely going out my mind
because my daughter was in Milan
so what I did was
uh thankfully she was on my passport my
British passport
so I got a family member to bring her to
the Border in France she and I got a
flight to nice
got the train went together at the
border of intermedia I think that's
called I went to Stover got her
and came away because my so in Italy you
have you made a name and you keep that
so my name is dejovina my maiden name so
if they were lucky if someone it was
dejovina but on my own British passport
it was my recall
my husband's name
so I thought I can't I'd rather be in
prison and be without my daughter I have
to risk and go and get my daughter
and then I came to the UK sort of kept
my head down
which wasn't much good because I
transferred the money from a Swiss bank
account to an English bank account and
bought myself a house
and thought I could just get laid low
and no the customer like size came a
year later 90 June 94.
so what was the prison sentence what for
how long did you get into I got three
years nine months in the UK for money
laundering because I moved the money
from Switzerland into the UK
and I got uh 10 years in Italy that was
an extradited to Italy
and I got 10 years over there which was
then because I sort of pleaded sort of
guilty
it got reduced to six years
what about your dad and your nan what
was happening to them were they still
involved in the crowd no they were by
that time they were in prison
so when the arrests came
I tried to avoid but I couldn't the year
after
my nan was arrested in the first 93 my
dad was inside in Portugal the whole
family was in prison
by then so and doing you know they got
30 years life
um my my dad and my non and I got 30
years a knife
because of what I mentioned before that
I hit from ligamara
of allowing it to happen
even though he was indirectly they said
you know they'd give him the go-ahead
uh yeah and so what happened to you and
um she was on uh she came out
oh God I I
managed to see them in 2013 I hadn't
seen them
for 13 years my father as well I didn't
see him for all that time I saw him at a
trial
and I managed to see my number and buy
them on Amazon house arrest
uh because of health-wise health so
that's and that's what I mentioned she
died on house arrest
what about your dad my sister wrote to
him I've got a younger sister and saying
that she felt an orphan and she's this
and that
and it hit something somewhere and he
just thought I've had enough I'm going
to die in here I'm not gonna you know
I'm not I've got my children are wands
in prison the other this and
and he said that he's changed his life I
said the only way I'm going to be able
to change my life am either going to die
in here and go out and do everything
over again because that's the life I own
no I only know that life he basically
told everything that he'd done given up
everything that he had
anything that they didn't manage to get
he gave it to the authorities
his left witness protection now he's
living
and Norm is a chef now
[Laughter]
he's a chef in Italy
um which is good you know he's left that
life behind he's gone which you never
think you know I thought it had a dying
prison or down the streets to be honest
because of the life that he led
when you look
back at it all
what are you feeling like is there
anything you regret he said there's a
lot of Africa
and then once the hurt I caused my
mother
my child at the time she's very young
thankfully
she's turned out okay she's a good girl
you know she's
um
I think that's my biggest regret my
my mother and hurt you know and
indirectly hurting other people somehow
if I could if I could take back the
indirectiveness of hurting people I will
take that back
definitely any day it straight away you
know you know that's that's the thing
that
and not just my mother and just anybody
in directly that's been hurt with this
with the organization with because there
will have been through the drugs they
bought through the you know it's down
the line the ripples
of of the damage that you've caused
thankfully I've turned it around I've
I've bettered myself out of something
bad I'm making good positive
people say oh but you're a different
person from that man
I'm not I'm still me I was still like
this then
I just learned to
not see life like that and learn to do
different things in life it's almost
like you're learning to habilitate to
understand that was wrong
you know I never wanted that anyway it
was circumstances he was born into it it
was
and so now it's I mean I three years ago
I was something for a cleaner
it's not I'd rather clean someone else's
toilets and go down them lines again
this is what I'm trying to say you know
you you you have to reinvent yourself
you have to re
again I always strength to
to have another life as in a better life
you just need to be willing enough and
strong enough to
and have the right people around you
support and love and your family
[Music]
in 1975 I actually took an oath with
five other gentlemen became a sworn made
member of the family
and just to show you how fortunate I am
the Five Guys that I took the oath with
they were all murdered later on every
one of them none of them survived